[Music]
the most magical day of the year
it is line up day what podcast which
bands this year that matters lord taco
berry porter i'm brad steiner i i can't
believe it's actually here we we're good
at the lineup part barry we're not so
good at the festival part um i don't
know if uh we can do lineups all the
time
in fact let's do a few more lineups it
doesn't really mean we're going to have
a festival it's true
that's true we've had lots and lots of
practice yeah we've got the lineup thing
down now we should point out again
because we're actually going to do this
yeah point out again the longest running
podcast about an event that hasn't
happened that hasn't happened sure um
i i can't believe it's it's actually
happening and there's a part of me that
um
maybe i don't know maybe i'm alone on
this but boy i have tapped out for so
long on this kind of stuff i didn't
follow any of the rumors i didn't follow
any of the
leaks uh up until like yesterday and the
day before and like a week ago that's it
i just been tapped out and i
kind of would
suggest that to a lot of people
because it's been glorious not worrying
about this i'm so glad to hear you say
that because i thought man am i what am
i missing here if i am am i just that
old which i know you're gonna say i am
but uh well i'll be honest with you i
sort of missed i tweeted this out
earlier i miss blam do you remember blam
and how fun that was where we all got
together and hung out and we all went to
uh mellow mushroom that one week or that
one night and we had a big lineup reveal
party we watched blam together and
called a phone number and every time we
called we got a different person on the
lineup it was so much fun
and now we just wait around till noon
[Laughter]
and then we have fun talking about it
and then
we rethink it a week later talk about it
some more yeah i get really excited and
say it's the greatest lineup ever then
two weeks go by and i'm like man i
really hate this yeah
yeah i'm never going again ever gonna
hate it
um
all right so uh the lineup is out and um
should we do this first
first
we've done this is our fifth year and i
thought maybe we should do a quick sort
of uh what do you you call it in in the
biz a reset
there might be people who uh who don't
know who we are and why we're here and
what we're talking about the reset
should be my hair i just rolled out of
bed what's going on here guys is it all
right do we need to start over why don't
you go fix that
[Laughter]
um
yeah i so you do the reset i'll i'll
leave that up to you it's all you barry
well i'm i'm barry i work for the
chattanooga times free press brad is uh
in radio brad steiner works
nope
brad with the hair
what do you your program what you what
is your title yeah program director
operations and a radio cluster in new
orleans and uh baton rouge but um and
then uh
that's ring gold in the bus yeah and the
bus has always
yeah i don't really do anything i just
sit in the bus and drink pbr all day my
man carries it carries us
but uh we've been going brad and i
combined
almost 30 years it's 15 each or so i
mean i will say it's pretty amazing that
this is the start of season five i mean
this is not uh something that we never
we never anticipated doing it like this
more than a year um we just what i
wanted something to do yeah if you're
just now joining we started this uh in
2017
um 2018 just to talk about how much we
love the festival
uh the logistics yeah the lineup was was
light and we had nothing else to talk
about right
and uh we found that people all over the
country and even the world like it as
much as we do and in the last year it's
developed you're gonna fidget what's
going on with my hair what's happening
here today
and we just figured out that a lot of
people like not only bonnaroo but all
kinds of festivals as much as we do so
that's why we are here consequence
picked us up what eight nine ten months
ago were part of their network
um
because they like music and festivals
too so
anyway i just thought if somebody just
dropped in like who the heck are these
guys who are these idiots these are
these mooks that's that's how we got
here
what's a mook
i'm sorry barry that's the moops
yeah um i uh i will say you know and
maybe it's because of the two years that
we've gone through this um the the lead
up to this for me i insinuated earlier i
just i have not been right into it i
really have not been into it and i guess
you know i found out a week ago where
the big rumor was that the dixie chicks
were going to be our first female
headliner after you know lizzo was on
the lineup twice
uh i mean
i read that and i was like there's no
possible way that that in in 2021 that
is a relevant headliner and i'll start
there i think that if we were to pick a
name that was available to be your first
female headliner lizzo was not the one i
think we were all you know settled on
stevie nicks being that's that's
appropriate that's pretty solid pick
that's appropriate even even even though
i've heard from so many people that go
to her shows and say
you know it's really 50 50. if you get
her on a night where she's doing some
fleetwood mac stuff you're fine but if
she's doing her stuff it is a snooze
fest so i have no idea what to expect
but i'm betting that's you know
i would hope because of the history of
bonnaroo in that sunday night you know
legacy act
doing just hit after hit after hit i
hope it's at least you know you know
it's interesting
she's in that same stratosphere stevie
wonder used to be that way
um bob dylan
that way
van morrison you know just depending on
what night you get yeah just depends but
another one by the way van morrison
another one i i just i
i can't believe they haven't made a call
you know van morrison just seems like he
would fit a saturday afternoon so
perfectly at bonnaroo
that's way up there on my list yeah me
too um okay so i start with stevie nicks
and uh
i'll just go through
uh your first impressions and then we'll
go line by line what do you think so far
after you spent uh here at uh you know
ten o'clock in the morning on a uh like
yeah we got it a little bit early so
looking at it uh i think your first
reaction was
and then more i taco and i looked and
talked while you were getting set up
there's a
it's not top heavy for me stevie nicks
is a is definite
i want to see the others i will go and
see
um
the second line and then some of the
under undercar people there's a lot in
there for me
robert plant allison krauss i've seen
she's always terrific and you know he's
an icon
so you got to go see it
king gizzard i'm glad to see on there
goose we've been talking about since
their virtual
bonnaroo
uh japanese breakfast owes us a do-over
um
kristen moroney's on there we like
isaiah rashad's a chattanooga guy well
hang on a second you you're going way
too fast
start start with your initial impression
your initial impressions is that even
though the top doesn't do anything for
you there's nothing there that you like
huh
on the top
well in the the whole festival you mid
card down you feel like there's enough
in there for you oh enough in there yeah
i thought you said nothing yeah there's
enough in there um
and
i fully expect to find some folks that
i've you know are new to me
um so yeah
taco
it's good there's there's enough i think
from 2020 and 2021 to kind of like slide
in there that you know we'll be good to
pick up that we didn't get to see
um there's something every day that that
i'm interested in so
um my initial impression was man i
really feel old for the first time in my
bonnaroo life this makes me feel very
old um it won't be the last time what's
that yeah i know you're kidding it won't
be the last time i uh much of that
because i was thinking about this goes
back to what you were saying earlier
where you sort of checked out i mean
there's there's a lot of
i wonder how many new acts
have come along in the last two and a
half years that i just don't know about
because i've sort of checked out well i
mean look i think the first impression
of this and and maybe a lot of these
that you don't know barry is because a
lot of this is the most electronic heavy
lineup that they've ever put out and i
think that if you're electronic music
fan this is just um a dream come true
for you
if you are a if you're a classic
bonnaroo person you probably want to
throw
up all over your clothes so you know
it's gonna have
it's gonna i have a feeling it's gonna
be really polarizing and you know at
first pass and i you know i'm going to
reserve the right to change my mind but
at first pass of this
um it feels like when
your ex starts dating someone else
when
you start looking around and you're like
oh they've moved on
because
this doesn't feel like the same festival
that
i
was so excited about two years ago the
lineup that came out two years ago was
one of the greatest festival lineups
we've ever seen and it never came to
fruition so we got a watered-down
version of it last year and now it feels
like there's just it it's totally
different i mean this feels like a
um
an operation that's not being ran by
the guys
yeah the same people anymore uh better
or worse i don't know but this doesn't
feel like the bonnaroo
lineups of old all right i'll give you
that uh yeah
there's some there's some lanes in there
there's some acts in there that feel
like bonnaroo of old but probably not
percentage wise to your point
um i'll give you that
and
you know
some of that
has to happen i mean we've both done it
enough that there have been several
years where i felt like that or or the
put it this way the perception from the
masses was that that's what's happened
this is not the same bonnaroo yeah well
i mean they've done that several times
well i think recent c bias comes into
play with a lot of this stuff and and
that's why it's always the worst lineup
ever the greatest lineup ever you know
we we have this recency bias that only
accounts for this amount of time that's
ever existed in the history of time so
you know i don't want to go crazy and
say you know worst greatest anything
it's just you know
first off if if anybody thinks that
booking a festival at this point in in
the world is easy
look at coachella coachella is is the
stories that i've heard come out of
coachella as to why this band pulled out
or this artist doesn't want to do it or
this person's asking for this
i mean it's so bad [ __ ] crazy barry that
i don't even want to repeat it because
it could it doesn't sound right i mean
the the demands on the writers that are
changing on the daily so that you know
one person gets this and one the other
person gets that because the ex of the
girlfriend the boyfriend
it's nutty the stuff that i've heard
come out of coachella just in that world
it's hard to book but imagine now trying
to you know add covet on top of it and
um you know budgets being slashed in
half
i don't know how you book a lineup to be
honest with you i this so just putting
something out congratulations you
deserve all the credit in the world um
yeah i totally agree and i i keep
thinking of our conversation with uh
stephen and brian several years ago for
that amazing lineup you know when you
had two guys doing it
and there was no covet everything was
pretty much
you know they could not pick and choose
but a lot more so than today
so i agree i mean i i can't imagine what
all they've
had to deal with
people changing their minds acts
breaking up you know moving on
going over whatever
okay
i mean i i you can you can put it you
can put it within the covid uh bucket if
you want to but you know there is
if you just go with surface level here
it's a tad schizophrenic this lineup is
a tad schizophrenic and in some ways
sometimes it's really good you know you
can find a lot of different uh bizarre
things
when it's this schizophrenic but man um
when you have
i don't know what the rationale with
booking machine gun kelly is
but um there's no world
where i understand it
uh you could you can sell me on a
million different things but um there is
nobody in this industry that makes me
scratch my head more than machine gun
kelly and
frankly if it if the argument was a
ticket play
i don't really even know if he's if he
sells that many tickets um he didn't not
every one of his tour dates was sold out
on his tour for his for his latest album
uh he came to new orleans and you know i
the report was before it got shut down
because of covet they sold less than 5
000 tickets for a you know 15 000
um you know person festival
i don't really understand the rationale
because he fits nothing that this
festival
is about
um
you know tulle and stevie nicks are the
closest they may be the chicks even i
mean you could even convince me that the
chicks fit more about what the bonnaroo
um mentality is supposed to be than any
of them but the rest of it i'm really
struggling to figure out
if this is a bonnaroo lineup or just
another festival lineup
does that make sense yeah or what you
know best they could do this year
um
i don't know i'm gonna wait and see on
that one my worry was
uh like russ said earlier that there
would be days that i didn't couldn't
find anything and
uh
i'm i'm okay with just about every day i
know only two names on thursday i'll be
honest with you but we all know thursday
is discovery day so that doesn't bother
me
um
but i'm giving you one right now the dip
right down the dip right that is a fun
show
isn't that a wasn't that a song by frick
nasty
yeah it's what you nicknamed your never
mind um
but you know
the other one that makes me laugh is
uh i don't wanna okay i'm just gonna say
it and if i get in trouble i get in
trouble but um how the brook and the
bluff still makes their way to festivals
um
is beyond comprehension to me i know
that the guys might be very nice people
but the people that um
are their representatives
they have done the best sales job on
this band that i've ever
i've ever seen because there's just
there's just no metrics to back this up
but yet they find themselves on every
festival lineup in the world i okay um
now you want to see them yeah well
you had them in chattanooga
we did them at uh we did them for the um
the first moon river festival they were
there
they were there at shakines too
are you saying they left their way in
well you know if you wanted a nice nap
in the middle of the day that's your
band that's the guys for you
god love them though i mean i i don't
mean to to
dog on them it's just it's it's pretty
remarkable they keep finding themselves
on on festival items um so
all right so that's my initial
impression i i don't want to
dislike it but
the mere fact that machine gun kelly is
on a lineup makes me so
uncomfortable um because he just doesn't
fit anything that's that that festival's
about the second band that sticks out
like a sore thumb for me and it's
because of some recent news that came
out about their guitar player and some
underage girls that was
uh that he was accused of
all-time low has gone through it the
last six months and they've seen a lot
of their shows get cancelled they've
seen a lot of their um
shows become under attended now i don't
know if that's because of kovid but also
they've got some serious stuff out there
accusations against the guitar player um
with underage girls now um
a lot of that could be incorrect but
it is very surprising that bonnaroo is
you know rolling the dice um especially
when they have
a very female
presentation
on their top line i'll put it this way
don't have a female presentation but
they are definitely making sure that
they
uh
put females
first for the first time
now by the way does that mean lizzo's
the first ever female headliner or will
stevie next be the first ever female
headliner even though lizzo actually
didn't perform
yeah it depends on how we define it
probably gonna i mean should that
it could be written that liza was the
first female artist booked as a
headliner for sure
by guys like me yeah but stevie will be
the first to have actually done it
if it happens
um okay so those are my first two
thoughts now i'll go let's just start
with the headliners um you know there's
not much that you're going to get from
us on these headliners you know
you're not looking at the biggest tool
fans
um
you're not looking at hip hop fans i'm
i'm excited about tool i'm glad they
might be on there yeah are you
yeah i'm gonna go see him i'm not a huge
fan but doing you know uh
went listening back to some stuff and uh
i could i could definitely hear them on
the farm they fit what sure what you and
i talk about all the time
sure you know you can hear it in that
big field for sure i i agree you know
stevie nicks like i've said
icon i want to see j cole
i listen to one song and you know my i i
really only have
one or two rules
no misogyny and you know
i'm not a big
if you can't think of a better word i
don't i don't want to hear it so
i won't be there yeah well j cole has
what
i i really don't like being this
negative i really don't but by all
accounts that 2015 j cole show was one
of the
one of the worst
shows
of maybe a bonnaroo history uh i i just
don't know many people that um that had
positive things to say about that show
but i mean if you went and you liked it
then more power to you uh but it's
surprising that they that they bring
that kind of stuff back um it was
instead of going through thursday uh any
thoughts on
um any of the other headliners any of
the top lines the chicks illinium flume
21 savage machine gun kelly roddy rich
it's almost as if they created
three headliners each day that perfectly
fit each other
yeah okay
you know my mike i said to you yesterday
when we thought the chicks were going to
be on the lineup um and i think you're
right in that it does feel like they
were going to get a female headliner and
they they probably found stevie
and i don't know what the chick's show
is these days but my first thought was
i don't want to be coming out of this
two and a half years and being preached
at
um
didn't you see you didn't see them at
the moon river i thought they were great
they moved checks yeah no
no
the dixie chicks played moon river
i don't know no no no no no no
no uh i don't know who you're thinking
of but um are you thinking about brandy
carlisle oh no it was the um it was the
uh
oh barry it's that band that uh female
band that you love so much
oh god what the hell was the name of
that band i don't remember but no it
wasn't the dixie chicks i don't know if
the dixie chicks have done a show
in
i i wouldn't even know where to guess i
couldn't tell you the last time the
dixie chicks did an actual show i mean
they put it on an album and i don't
think anybody cared oh by the way it's
the chicks i can't we're not supposed to
be calling them mexi chicks anymore
um but they did an album and i don't
know if anybody really even paid
attention to it i don't think they
toured on it
so
you know again very odd pull but again i
will say i think it actually is one of
the more inspired
choices because of where it lands now if
you put it in the same slot as stevie
next we probably have some problems but
i have no problem with the chicks being
one two three four five six down seven
down i don't have any problem with that
no i it'll it'll be
it could be a good show could be a lot
of fun that my only hesitation is is i
just don't want to be preached at but i
don't care who that is
who the artist is
i'm going to tell you you know i know
that that
my first initial impressions they're all
painted i'm going to be very honest it's
all painted by machine gun kelly um so
you know again i reserved the right to
have this lineup grow on me but my
initial impression is so
much uncomfort and or discomfort rather
because of machine gun kelly but let's
go through friday which you know for a
guy like me there's a there's a lot
there uh robert plant allison krauss
um i think disclosure is going to sound
fine lord huron to me is i've had my
moments with them the war on drugs you
know i love with all of my heart um
i
he's just so creative i love this album
so much it's one of my favorite albums
of the year king gizzard is a band that
we've been um targeting for years goose
ever since seeing them on the the stream
was great i know that bleachers and jack
antonoff gets a rough go of it
by some people but i want
he used to be the guitar player for fun
fun was the only band in the history of
bonnaroo
to have a number one single while they
were playing bonnaroo right that in of
itself is incredible and they were one
of the biggest last minute additions on
the bonnaroo poster maybe you know ever
you know there's not been a lot of you
know high level editions at the last
minute like jimmy buffett is one of them
but fun was one of those last minute
editions and jack antonoff got his first
you know bonnaroo uh that year with fun
now jack antonoff is back
not only doing
the bleacher show but also
the super jam um i have no idea what
jackanoff's 1984 is
but
um
the dude's creative the dude knows what
he's doing and i don't hate the new
bleachers album
i don't hate it uh it you know i know it
it it's polarizing to some people but
you know it could be a lot worse um
like you said isaiah rashad chattanooga
kid
uh came out of nowhere
at least an hour
even in our city
people didn't see that coming right big
big what hit six months ago yeah
so look at him he's on the third line on
friday yeah i'm excited
i'm excited to see it
he's got to be the biggest chattanooga
artist to ever play bonneville
it's got to be
yeah i can't think of anybody bigger at
this point
uh so then still woozy and i haven't
even left the third line yet i love
still woozy so now you go to the next
line uh denzel curry and japanese
breakfast tovlo day glow
and then i think it's going gonna be the
crown jewel of friday
i
am in love with arlo parks she had one
of my favorite songs of the year i love
that album so much oh man at arlo parks
early in the afternoon show on friday
will be the first time the first show of
the the weekend that really gets me
going um is
man if i stress anything to you barry
taco go listen to arlo parks but let me
come back to
uh japanese breakfast for a second
because you said earlier we are oda
do-over
uh
she's had an amazing michelle's gonna be
on the show with us this season and
she's had a pretty amazing year not only
she's you know had a album that has been
critically acclaimed by every hipster
you know
magazine blog on the planet but also
she's got a number one new york times
bestseller she wrote a book as well um
i
can't wait to ask her
how the diff what the difference is
between the band from three years ago
when they played bonnaroo to now because
one of the most i odd one of the most
odd shows we have ever been to as a
group was watching japanese breakfast
take 40 minutes to sound check and then
to play 25 minutes afterwards and their
set was over yeah
no exaggeration at all that's exactly
what happened it was so strange and and
every time we looked around they're like
well there was a there was a hip-hop guy
that played before
and i kept wondering like i thought they
were like the first ones on the stage
they were pretty if they weren't first
they were second they were second
like how this was so strange and and the
reason why i never bought that as an
excuse was i watched them
do
the
uh hey bill he will say sorry hay bale
sessions backstage right inside the
trailer there's like two or three people
they get to sit in there and watch you
record something for bonnaroo radio and
they had done that and i swear to god
had they not spent half an hour sound
checking i wouldn't have believed you
that they spent half an hour sound
checking on the mains on this tent so
there was something just not connecting
in that space and for them to come back
to bonnaroo i i am so intrigued with
what her
what that transition was like and how
different that band must be now yeah i
agree it was weird wasn't it taco i mean
it was intentional it wasn't like
something broke or
you know they were trying to hurry it
was they just taken their time
and they took their time over and over
oh my gosh it was pretty brutal
it was it was like are we getting
trolled like is this real like should we
go somewhere else and do something else
like what's going on it was it's so
strange somebody goes on the show
started you know how when you're
watching a band sound check and then
they start playing a song and like okay
they got it figured out now it's time to
nope nope they kept doing that over and
over and over they were playing snippets
of songs like is this is this like a
remix
you know saint paul came out what the
next year
and did a sound check and we all kind of
went crazy but it was about 30 seconds
or maybe 60 seconds and he just kind of
waved and went back off stage
and then they started that
that's even unusual but the japanese
breakfast thing was crazy i've never
seen anything like it let me go the next
line on uh on friday because uh there's
some interesting stuff here so ty verdes
the regrets briston maroney weren't
there regrets on thursday last year the
year before uh no that was like five
years ago barry has it been that long
four years ago we interviewed the
regrets
backstage at bonnaroo and it was one of
the most
odd
chats we've ever had and they were
children i mean i don't give them any
blame in this whatsoever we were more to
blame than anybody but it was we were
very unprepared it sounded terrible and
we were talking to children yeah literal
children and i i felt really bad about
the interview we didn't air it and now
they actually have
a year that's i mean this year could be
a really big year for them um they've
got a song that's you know starting to
move on alternative radio uh my
station's playing it we have a show with
them in a month uh they seem to have
their [ __ ] together and especially the
people that backed them i mean she's
she's like best friends with billy
eilish you know so she's got phineas
connections so they're set up to have a
really good run here uh that's the one i
would watch but the
of course bristol maroney's been on the
show before uh ty verdes is a
he'll probably be on the show this year
this kid's you know sort of a pop
alternative act um he's got a pretty big
hit at pop radio but the one i want to
the other one i want to point you to
other than arlo parks on friday
i love claude
c-l-a-u-d
i love her i love her i love her talk
about another song that was in my top
fives of the year i
she's incredible uh my buddy chris
mukley at siriusxmu probably the guy
that found her and uh started you know
blowing her up on on on siriusxmu but
man um
i know there's in my own i can talk out
of both sides of my mouth here i know
that i'm irritated and sort of
uncomfortable with with machine gun
kelly and
j cole and roddy rich
and flume
21 savage but you know i started digging
in on friday that's a lot yeah i mean i
just rattled on 15 bands that i could
watch on friday that's what i'm saying
it's it's uh
it's better than than at uh first blush
yeah there's definitely
all right you want to take saturday you
want to what do you think about saturday
saturday is probably for me
the
the not weaker it's the one where i know
fewer people okay uh tool like i said
i i can picture them on the farm um and
definitely want to check it out
billy strings
uh
you know talking about zeitgeist i know
what two years ago he was
he was everybody's next big thing or one
of them
uh mark rivulet is um
was on
what the last two or one
um look i i don't care what anybody says
about mark that dude's show is so
fun yeah
yes you can you can you can dog him out
all you want to for being a goofball or
whatever but that show is a blast it is
an absolute blast
yeah
and then uh
ludacris i'll go that's a for sure i
gotta check out all right well i'm gonna
stop you at luna chris because there's
other ones you know in there that that i
want to talk to talk about before you
get to ludacris like for instance
churches churches canceling you know
their germany dates to come over to uh
america and do uh to do bonnaroo mount
joy also been on the show before uh but
ludicrous
would you rather have nelly or ludacris
ludacris me personally
chris but but we've already seen the
show it was he was just here
you saw it i didn't see it he just did
this
yeah i didn't see it and what has he
done between then and now
to make that show any different again uh
these are
part of the thing that i like about this
festival and festivals in general is
that i i wouldn't buy a ticket for you
know
90 of them or 95
but the fact that i can see him
along with everything else it's worth
it's worth checking out i know but i i
think you're missing my point he was
just at bonnaroo
you know that's one of those things that
comes up every now and then with
bonnaroo fans but they repeat acts all
the time i know that but most most acts
like do aleppo do alipa who was there
one year and then came back the next
year to get on the main stage at least
put an album out that year fair enough
what is louis chris
i can't i can't answer i don't know i
don't know what the show is going to be
different i don't know what's different
about the show
i have no idea okay um
so then you get judah and lyon and mount
joy and then we come to uh uh all-time
low uh by the way mount joy i'm sorry
judah the lion is going to be on uh this
season with us um
i like slow tie slow tie is a really fun
one and then come to ash ash has got a
little bit of heat especially on the
west coast
the
the la kids really like the ash uh she's
got some phineas connections
as well uh and then you know our our old
favorite from years and years and years
ago that i think it might even be the
very first ever root clue is the
pigeon's playing ping-pong
um somebody might with with a better
historical accuracy tell me if bitchin's
playing ping pong was the first ever
real clue but i think that they might be
that's how long they've uh they've been
around
and how much the banaru people love them
yeah all right that's yeah that's that's
our champion
that's the only one left on the list
that i have any clue about to be honest
really well let me introduce the
backseat lovers i like these guys a lot
um they could they they can get into
they don't jam but they get into some
long
um pieces a really good rock outfit i
think they deserved a better shot at
radio um they've got a song called kilby
girl that i'm a big big fan of uh and
outfit what do you dick clark all of a
sudden
he's a tall drink of water he's a good
look there's a good little combo of
these guys
[Laughter]
uh and then uh femi cootie
femi cootie um
uh and then oh our boy patrick droney is
back
do you remember patrick drony i do you
remember the name yeah i do
yeah three years was it three years ago
we we we brought this name up we're like
who is patrick drony and then we ended
up liking the song did we even have him
on the show
did we talk to patrick drony
i don't know if we talked to him
yeah he did like it i think we actually
had that kid on the air i think
well we said we were going to remember
we said we're going to have a big meet
up at the patrick jones show didn't we
was that it i mean it might have been
but we never went to the gym
but we actually never went to the
patrick dronie show even though he's got
that one song that we all seem to like
that none of us can remember that can
remember right he's a good singer man i
like that he's a good singer songwriter
yep yeah yeah all right now again i go
through this and we're all the way to
sunday and i've skipped over every
electronic act and i'm sorry about that
i just don't have it i don't i don't
have
the combination to the lock that is
electronic music i have been very open
about this i don't know any of these
artists and i don't necessarily think i
should be talking about something that i
have no idea about
yeah i and i don't think graph to
apologize either i mean you can't like
everything
oh it's just not my lane i mean i just
don't know who
shipwreck is
no i i i think
i don't apologize
you know you can't like everything you
can't know everything and it always
bothers me when people try to act like
oh yeah i know that
oh you don't know you don't know yeah
you comment they'll do it
i quit trying to do that a long time ago
because i kept getting caught yeah
oh my god i did one the other day oh i
felt like the biggest [ __ ] i was
talking to a record guy i'm not gonna
say the band i'm not gonna say the band
but i was so convinced
so convinced the certain sound of this
band and he's like are you sure you're
not talking about blankety blankly no no
it is not like that and then i did a
quick google search and i couldn't have
been more wrong yeah you know i could
not have been more wrong you know i
thought that like insert how does tyler
who was rufus a soul i got it so
completely wrong i thought it was like
some sort of like
i'll forget it it doesn't matter i just
like i said i've done it
how many times uh get to sunday and um i
think to me the one that stands out and
the one that
if there's a can't miss on sunday
uh i mean
who
would pass up the opportunity of seeing
herbie hancock
who
who would do this
talk about an absolute banger parade
that is going to be the most fun show of
the entire weekend
and i don't know if anybody will talk
about it um well it may fall in that uh
lionel richie
uh category where you don't think people
you know but
but bonnaroo folks are a pretty
intelligent crowd
most of them know their history and
between uh he and stevie nicks
man that's a lot of rock and roll music
history right there so
yeah it don't pass up seeing herbie
um with that being said uh the artist
that i love the most on this day is
nathaniel raytliff um i'm obsessed with
nathaniel ray live i love the new album
um
plus i just love walking around the
house screaming son of a [ __ ]
i love the idea of just walking down the
street looking like the way that he
looks and somebody just screaming son of
a
i want [ __ ]
see that one yeah
and i and i have a feeling that that
you'll find nathaniel raytliff if he's
there throughout the weekend he'll pop
up everywhere that dude just loves
playing and he just he just just doesn't
need much you know he's just one of
those guys that just shows up and can
be cool look cool act cool play cool
everything about him is is just a
personification of cool
i want to see all them witches too
me too that's that's been on my list
okay um
so you got uh of course rez puts a fire
wallows um sort of a um
i mean i don't want to get too crazy
here and mean but a little bit of a
whiny alt rock band uh tash sultana oh
god i love her she's just they she might
be a be honest with you i don't know the
proper pronoun but
incredible artist coin from nashville
nashville's own coin um you know they're
at the river were they not talking they
were yes they were they're expecting
some big things out of them and then um
a girl that i met in miami
years and years ago her name is fletcher
she had a massive hit like three four
years ago um and just really really
hasn't been able to capture that
lightning in a bottle again um i kind of
think that she wants to be
if you remember the artist a couple
years ago banks um
you know she's got a little bit of that
in her
the jaded ex-girlfriend
route is sort of her angle and um i
really hope she does well because i find
her to be just an absolute sweetheart uh
who who
you know
in fact
did i have her running in the chihuahuas
i was just thinking that i think i did i
asked you
i think i might have i'm almost sure
that you did
i might have done that that's true she's
been here and i'm i'm pretty sure you
your radio station brought her here i
think so um you got the lettuce in there
too and um that's about all i can talk
about on sunday uh you you you skipped
over crucifer real quick but that's
another yeah that's that's another
maynard band yeah yeah yeah that's
that's a that's a lord taco angle i uh i
i i couldn't
i don't think i could pick out one of
their songs
i think i could do it
i mean i really have i have a ton i
don't know how many i don't know how
many of their songs we could say on the
show
oh yeah
i smell a game i smell a game coming
[Laughter]
nice see you found a bunch we all found
we all found enough and like i said we
haven't even done the deep dive yet so
uh you know there'll be some acts on
there that i know i will have never
heard of that i'll end up liking
but you might be right there might be a
whole lot more edm that i'm aware of
uh yeah
there's no babies there's no babies on
this line a little no babies really uh
basically really a good point there is
not one baby for lord toxicity one baby
little babies duh babies i don't see
them that's hard to do in this day and
age i mean why do they hate babies
yeah what do they have what's honor's
anti-baby policy
they're anti-babyites
somebody get them on the phone right now
and figure out why they hate babies so
much
i don't know why why are they so uh
babist
why do you hate babies why do you hate
babies so much
uh dear dear ashley capps
what is your problem with babies he
leaves and they hate babies what is your
problem with babies
i'm i'm looking through some some [ __ ]
fur
uh song titles i don't see anything
that's too outrageous here bullet
trained iowa the underwhelming kill mom
kill dad kill
kill kill kill
uh
wait is that not real
i don't see anything i don't see
anything too too crazy here but yeah
that's a that's a maynard that's another
maynard band
so i don't have a problem with tool i
really don't and and look i i'm pretty
honest and forthright when it comes to
the you know things that i like and
dislike on the show but uh tool was
always difficult for me because i was
never able
to tell the difference between two and
nine inch nails
i always had a difficult time
deciphering the two
and yeah and there was just a moment in
the world where you know the tool sound
the nine inch nails sound and you could
probably even get to like marilyn manson
and and on
i just never got there right and never
connected i was on a different plane i
was in you know i was on nutrimonk hotel
and death cab and the shins and you know
whiny
you know
angsty [ __ ] like that i was never into
the tool and and
that side of it so i i don't know much
to say about it unfortunately um
yeah so like i said so i get it don't
have to punt to other people when it
comes to stuff like this
there's a whole period of music that i
missed because i was you know raising
babies or whatever so i understand you
know or my
maybe we can get raising babies for the
lineup raising babies yeah right there's
your babies so so barry is not anti-baby
barry not anti-baby that's serious pro
baby yeah
i am a baby so i'm pro-baby
[Laughter]
i'll be that baby
um
uh anything else anyway let's go through
any more oh yeah the super jam and then
finally the super jam of jack antonoff
um
boy uh they are really milking jack
antonoff uh there's something
in me that thinks that he might just
find himself somewhere else like a uh
you know like a like a
campground
late at night doing something um
something tells me they're gonna parade
him around like the haley williams of
2022.
probably i'm trying to look through the
rest of the release that we got early to
see if there's any big news we'll you
know we'll come back and talk about the
the camps and the
all those things tickets go on sale
thursday
uh for people who don't know
the one i don't know that i am
immediately intrigued by
black tiger sex machine
give me some more black tiger sex
machine
i do
see that they've added chattanooga
shuttles
really
how about that look at you that's new to
my knowledge they've had from nashville
but now they're hiding from chattanooga
so
well they added that last year but last
year didn't happen so that never
happened no people are still waiting on
that bus to go
they're still standing out there yeah i
paid for it
um but yeah we'll get into all that
later and several other things uh
we've talked i talked to
long time listeners will remember the
name jeff cuellar he's no longer with
live nation or ac but he has been with
had been with the festival since its
beginning
has changed jobs so he'll be a guest
coming up i'm looking forward to that he
has will have some great insights into
the industry and
changes and how it's developed and where
it's going and all that um and we
official and it's officially the start
of season five huh this is it that is
correct wow season five episode one what
are the big uh what are they changing we
don't have a new set um
uh we have we don't have it we haven't
added a new character do we have a love
triangle this year is there i'm trying
to think like what happens on the oc in
the new season so
um i added a dog hey dog marigold how
there's uh there's no dashboard so i
won't i won't uh pick up a dashboard mom
unfortunately you know the news just
came out this morning dashboard and
jimmy world are coming to new orleans i
saw them in march march 21st you ready
uh
maybe a lot of moms
there's a lot of moms i wonder who
the mom act is
for this oh yeah
you know you know what i bet that you
would do really well with dixie chick
moms
i bet there's gonna be a lot of moms at
the chick show
wear that pbr hat
that yep nothing right now
nothing sends thighs a quiver
[Laughter]
and we also should mention
i don't know when if it'll be this week
or next or how soon but we'll be talking
about some of the other festivals too
right the other lineup announcements i
mean if coachella ever happens we'll see
uh you know there there have been a few
that have come out over the last couple
of weeks that i'm actually really
intrigued by somebody's gonna have to
explain to me what fyf festival is um i
don't know how do you i don't is it fife
yeah i've never heard of it so i don't
know but this lineup is absolutely
incredible it has got everything that
i've ever wanted in a festival lineup in
one place um i i'd love to sort of dive
into that one because i don't know what
it is i've never heard of it and it's
somewhere in in la uh there's a redondo
beach
festival that's nothing but 90s bands
it's like smashing pumpkins 311
and then
weezer oh and
black pumas like it's just the weirdest
combination
but boy if you love the 90s head to
redondo beach um yeah there's a there's
a few more oh and then the other thing
that i found out is churches is going to
be doing a whole bunch of festivals
including uh acl later on this year like
they were i mean i think church was
there last year too um but you got the
acl festival coming i i just don't think
that you know voodoo is happening um you
know the buku lineup is out you know
there's there's several other festivals
that are coming
but the big one to drop is is coachella
and the fact that they can't seem to
find a third headliner
uh has gotten everybody here's let me
ask you guys this as as bonnaroo
lifers
if what was happening
with bonner it was happening at
coachella right now is happening with
bonnaroo how panicked would you be
uh
i panicked doesn't enter into it anymore
i mean after what we've been through
no i mean
you know
we've joked about it every year
lineup comes out we love it a week later
we hate it three months later we're not
going because they've changed the entire
universe around and they're screwing us
all up and then we go and it's great so
i just don't even
don't worry about it no not like that um
every i mean if it was two years ago
it would be concerning but so much has
happened like you said at the beginning
of the show that i just
you know it's wait and see
panic when it happens to me anymore
or if if panic is even the right word
but i understand what you're saying but
it's just you know
adapt i don't know how it's to put it
well man i i get i want to come back to
this one more time
uh first off uh i think that i'd be
really panicked and very confused if i
was a coachella lifer like we are
boundary life or i can't imagine what
they're going through where every day
they think they're getting a lineup and
then every day they're like oh we lost
another headliner let's start over
um but
man i keep coming back to this this
festival is about acceptance it's about
love it's about um
community it's about taking care of each
other
all of the the
wonderful things that we pull out of
bonnaroo
and one of their headliners is machine
gun kelly
i mean i just can't get around that i
can't get around it yeah
i did
changing the subject but you you
reminded me i've had several
conversations this week with people
involved
and you know we along with everyone else
has raised the issue of
communication
what happened you know with bonnaroo
they're always so great
at communicating marketing social media
all of that stuff and the reality is
just like we thought
they've just been short staffed
and when uh when the things started back
up
it was you know
uh drinking from a fire hydrant type of
stuff they had too much to do
um so
just what we thought it was i don't it
wasn't you know a conspiracy it was just
not enough people to do the job at hand
sure so
i mean that happens going forward i mean
that's why i think that any lineup that
you put out in this environment on the
scale of bonnaroo or coachella you know
is is a win congratulations i mean do
you get all the credit in the world uh
for being able to put something together
yeah um
but i mean i really could i mean i this
lineup would have been fine for me
if one
you're not gonna let that go i'm not
gonna let it go i really just can't let
it go
i'll tell you we had to like i
interviewed him i interviewed him about
a uh about a year ago in deep quarantine
and um
i just i've never like
you know i get it i i i've asked you i
don't understand i was doing laundry
i'll put it that way the guy was doing
laundry during the interview you know
like on video like emptying out his
dryer
i only multitask yeah
i mean it's impressive the man's doing
his own laundry honestly oh and the
other thing too about machine gun kelly
i will say he loves new orleans he
actually owns a house in new orleans he
uh was filming a movie here with pete
davidson for a while and um that's so
weird you say that man i was gonna say
that's the one act i don't get i've told
you that before i don't understand what
his talent is i don't understand why we
talk about him ever
yeah i mean before saturn live i mean he
was a pretty good comic i don't know
what he does on saturday night live but
anyway
that's my one so they're they're doing a
movie here and they always end up at
this bar and up town called the saint
and he loved this bar so much he bought
a house across the street
and that's hardcore i know i know i've
got a bar here in my neighborhood that i
don't want to leave the neighborhood
because it's my favorite bar i don't
there you go
but yeah i mean it's i will give him you
know that he does love the city of new
orleans he really does
he apparently loves that bar
it's a fun one november all right um
there you go anything else i guess it's
a time to start you know rallying the
troops and finding some uh some people
to talk to huh yep
all right yeah now we gotta put together
a whole season at this we gotta work are
we 16 weeks
something like that i think we're 16
weeks away
[Music]
consequence podcast network